>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington D.C.
>> Two Washington D.C. high school
students, Amaud Woodward [assumed spelling]
and Tanae Crumlin [assumed spelling]
meet award winning author Tanya Bolden,
to discuss the research and writing
process around her book entitled,
Capital Days: Michael Shiner's Journal.
The book spans more than 60 years of American
history, highlighting a period of immense change
in our country and its capital, much
of it witnessed by Michael Shiner.
Born enslaved but eventually able to secure
his freedom, Shiner left behind a rich journal,
which is housed at the library of Congress.
In his journal, Shiner recounted the
burning of a city during the war of 1812,
to the laying of the cornerstone
for the Washington Monument,
as well as the inauguration
of eleven presidents.
Much as she did, in her award winning books,
Maritcha and Searching for Sarah Rector,
Tonya Bolden expertly examines the
intricacies of American history
through the lens of one person's life.
>> I want to begin by asking you how did you
start your writing process with this book?
>> For this book, with panic.
Every book begins with panic.
10th book, 15th book, 18th book,
24th book, it begins with panic.
Because I think that this is new, it's
stuff that I've never done before.
Because no book is like the last one that I did.
Capital Days is not like Sarah Rector.
And then I kind of calm down
and then I go to the research.
That's what saves me.
And I think everything comes
out in the research.
>> So, how do you organize your
research for the writing process?
>> Ok. Well, for one thing I do, if I'm
getting newspaper articles from online --
>> Yes.
>> I tend to, because I don't know I don't
trust things I don't understand things --
>> Right.
>> I have to save them on my computer.
In case if I'm not just on their
site but I save it onto my computer.
And I've been better, I used to have like, it
would be like Michael Shiner in everything.
My drafts, my memos, everything
was in one folder.
But now I break out into newspaper articles,
other references and break it all out.
Because the trouble comes when you
do that research is you lose stuff.
>> Right.
>> So generally when I write also,
sometimes, I write and research.
And kind of switch back and forth.
I may be writing, this was in the past when
he talks about the hard year without summer,
and I put TK and say go find
out what that means.
You know, I look it up quickly
and I'll keep writing
and then I'll go back and
research what I don't know.
Sometimes I need to write it
out and put TK what I don't know
and then go back and fill in the blanks.
>> What does TK mean?
>> Well that say it just means to come,
although it doesn't make any sense,
but I think it's because it's
the only combination of letters
that don't exist in American English.
I don't think you'll find any word.
So it's easy to track in a manuscript.
You put TK and then find out, like TK
Mohammad Ali's trunks were TK color
and then go back in and say look.
And I think that's the rationality,
that's the only two,
the combination that you never find in a word.
>> That's deep, actually.
>> So, a lot of times and because I think
there's a difference between, you know,
kind of getting the arc [assumed
spelling] and getting the story out.
You can always find the details.
So I'll usually have a lot of TKs in my work
and just say ok you know where this is going
and then getting to a point and
saying, say at the end of, I guess,
he's reunited with his family
and then say ok now what?
Whoa, I've been so into Shiner I need to
talk about, ok what's the feel of D.C.?
What's the everyday life of Washington?
And then I say go read some newspapers
from around the time his family was freed.
And that's where I found out about
pickled oysters and how much a book cost.
I just went looking for articles
to give a flavor.
Because I think at different stages when you're
writing and then you'll find what you need.
>> So, being from New York,
did you have to any research
for primary and secondary sources there?
>> In New York?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. But you know what?
With this digitization age, is amazing
because I needed to read a lot of newspapers
from Washington in the 19th century, for
example The Daily National Intelligencer,
The Evening Star.
But I could do it, I had a
subscription to genealogy [inaudible].
So, you know, from my desktop I could
read all of these newspaper articles.
In the last, I guess,10, 15 years that
research has really become just amazing to do
because you can do so much from your computer.
You know, before you had certain people.
You know, research wasn't really
democratic because you had to have budget
to be able to travel to archives --
>> Right.
>> And spend time in cities to go through
archives, you know, and then you had to rely,
if you didn't have the money for that, then
you had to rely on all these secondary sources.
Whereas now it's so much online it's just, even
the photo research, you know is just amazing.
>> So, would you consider the
research process now is easier than --
>> I would say, well, it's easier to do.
We can access more material but you can
become so obsessive because there are
so many subscriber sites or free sites.
You can just go and go and
go and go and go crazy.
So at least I always think, well I'm
learning something I'll use in another book.
Because, you know, I'll go read
every article and then you go off on,
but see going off on tangents
is how I found Shiner.
I was researching for Sarah
Rector and I stumbled upon Shiner.
So, it has its benefits.
But it's much easier and less
expensive to research now.
You can dig deeper.
See the problem before was a lot of times you
deal with secondary sources and you get a quote.
Right?
>> Yes.
>> And you use it and you quote
it and you give your source.
But I started to notice sometimes I
would see a quote in a secondary source
and I would go try to find the original.
And very often I find that people, what they
will do is, they'll take a quote and kind
of manipulate it in a way so
that it illustrates their point.
But when you read the original quote you
say, that's not quite what they mean.
>> Right.
>> That's one thing I can do now.
I can go, if someone was quoting
The Evening Star, I can go now
and check The Evening Star
and use the primary source.
So, yeah.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov